One of the most famous and highest achieving couples in the world,...
...wealthy beyond imagination,...
...Bill and Melinda Gates met at Microsoft,...
...where they're best known as a power couple...
...for the work of their charitable foundation.
The news that they're planning to separate came out of the blue.
They both tweeted a statement.
"After a great deal of thought and a lot of work on our relationship,...
...we've made the decision to end our marriage."
The couple will continue to work together at their foundation,...
...but they say "we no longer believe we can grow together as a couple...
...in this next phase of our lives."
The Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation...
...has had a huge impact on the world of philanthropy...
...with billions spent fighting causes such as infectious diseases...
...and encouraging vaccinations in children.
Bill and Melinda Gates are presenting a united front...
...on the matter of their divorce...
...and the same is likely to apply to their foundation,...
...a global force for good even if their individual roles drift apart.
Bill Gates, who founded Microsoft in 1975,...
...is the world's fourth richest person...
...with a net worth of more than 100 billion dollars.
There's no word on any financial agreement between the couple.
They've asked for space and privacy for their family...
...as they begin to navigate their new lives.